This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“绝对真人。”2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及构建抗逆力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“%”，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就。必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我要做他最后一个目标。他休想就此脱身。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another December guest episode. It is so great to have you here. I am personally so excited for this episode and to have this specific guest on the podcast. Being a creative person these days, having an online presence, putting yourself out there can be tough. Even if you don't have an audience, people can be very critical of us when we are loud, proud and passionate about our dreams.
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个与你探讨20s（二十多岁）最大的改变、时刻和人生转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到又一期的十二月嘉宾访谈节目。很高兴你能来到这里。我个人对这期节目以及邀请到这位特殊的嘉宾来到播客感到非常兴奋。如今作为一个有创造力的人，在网上保持存在感，将自己展现给大众，其实并不容易。即使你没有什么听众，当我们对自己的梦想高调、骄傲且充满热情时，人们也常常会对我们大加批判。
One of my favorite creators talks about this a lot. How to manage comparison. How to let people misunderstand you. How to know when something is meant for you. She is the author of two books about being in your 20s and a content creator who is honestly living her dream, Carrie Bradshaw life. And today we got to have her on the podcast to really pick her brain about so many interesting things without further ado. here she is. Eli Rallo, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Thank you so much for having me.
我最喜欢的创作者之一经常谈到这一点。如何应对比较。如何让别人误解你。如何知道某件事是否命中注定属于你。她是两本关于二十多岁生活的书的作者，也是一位内容创作者，老实说，她过着她梦想中的“凯莉·布雷德肖”式的生活。今天我们请她来到播客做客，就许多有趣的话题深入挖掘她的想法。废话不多说。她来了。伊莉·拉洛，欢迎来到《The Psychology of Your 20s》。非常感谢邀请我。
I'm so excited. Yeah, me too. I feel like obviously we're in the middle of like our December guest month. And I was like, who better to have on the show than another queen of the 20 somethings, another queen of the 20s? If no one has heard about you, which I don't know how they haven't, can you tell us a little bit about yourself and how you kind of begin your career, to now being almost a three-time author? Yes, I am a content creator and writer. I'm based in New York and also Texas. I'm 27.
我太兴奋了。是的，我也是。我觉得显然我们正处于十二月嘉宾月的中间。当时我想，还有谁比另一位二十多岁女性中的女王、二十岁女王更适合来到这个节目呢？如果有人还没听说过你——虽然我不知道他们怎么会没听说过——你能简单介绍一下你自己，以及你是如何开始你的职业生涯，并走到现在即将成为三本书的作者这一步的吗？是的，我是一名内容创作者和作家。我常驻纽约，也常驻德克萨斯州。我27岁。
And I started making content in 2020 and I've sort of been making content ever since. And my new book, does anyone else feel this way out October 14th? So I'm in kind of the process of dealing with everything that comes along with like pre-publication for a book, which has just been so exciting. and it's so crazy like, I don't know when this is coming out, but when we're recording it,
我在2020年开始创作内容，之后基本上就一直在创作。我的新书《Does Anyone Else Feel This Way》将于10月14日出版？所以我目前正处于处理与图书出版前夕相关的一切事务的阶段，这真的太令人兴奋了。而且太疯狂了，我不知道这期节目什么时候播出，但当我们录制的时候，
it's going to be out in a week. So it's been just a whirlwind. Oh my gosh. I can relate. Like when my book came out at the start of the year, it's like this huge, huge buildup. And then it kind of just like do it. And then everything just, you know what I mean? Like you reach this like pinnacle. And the day that you release, the book is often like the least exciting day. I don't know if you found that with your last book. Yeah. With my last book, definitely did. With this book, I definitely have a lot going on more than the last one. The last one, I was kind of like, okay, it's just here now and I'm going to go see my book in bookstores, which I did. And that was a really special moment. But then I didn't have any like huge, I guess I did a book tour that
它将在一个星期后出版。所以这真是一段旋风般的日子。哦天哪。我感同身受。就像我的书在今年年初出版时一样，前期会有巨大的、铺天盖地的造势。然后就好像是，终于完成了。然后一切就，你知道我的意思吗？就像你达到了一个顶峰。而你发布这本书的那一天，往往是最不令人激动的一天。我不知道你对上一本书是否有同感。是的。我的上一本书确实如此。对于这本书，我手头上的事情确实比上一本要多得多。上一本的时候，我基本上是觉得，好吧，它现在就在这儿了，我要去看书店里的书，我也确实去了。那是一个非常特别的时刻。但我并没有什么巨大的，我想我确实做过一次图书巡回签售，就在那。
night. But I didn't have like huge plans. This time, I have like a fully packed schedule for the release week. So it's kind of a crazier moment in time. But I think a lot of gratitude because I can compare it. I can compare and contrast both of my sort of book release weeks and feel really grateful for growth and, you know, all the steps in the right direction. So it's crazy, but it does really feel kind of anticlimactic emotionally because you're like, here's this thing I've been working on and now it's here. I know. And it's like, this is the thing that I have given like everything to and I've like poured my whole heart into. I remember the day I released mine. I like went to find it in a bookstore and it wasn't there. And I was like just walking around being like, oh. And it took me like a couple days.
天晚上。但我并没有什么宏大的计划。而这一次，我在新书发售周的日程安排得满满当当。所以这是一个更疯狂的时刻。但我心中充满了感激，因为我可以做个对比。我可以对比我这两次书的发售周，对成长以及朝着正确方向迈出的每一步感到非常感激。所以这很疯狂，但在情感上确实让人觉得有点虎头蛇尾，因为你会想，这就是我一直努力的东西，现在它终于面世了。我懂。这就好像，这是我倾注了所有心血、毫无保留地投入进去的东西。我记得我发布自己那本书的那天。我跑去书店找它，结果发现没有。我当时就在那儿转悠，心想，哦。我花了整整好几天。
it? Yeah, I was like, sometimes it takes a while for them to like get it into rotation. I didn't know this about bookstores. Yeah, the things you learn. Okay, this is a question that I've been really enjoying asking people recently, which is what did you want to be when you grew up now that you are a content creator and an author? Was that always the goal? I wanted to be a writer and I wanted to be on Broadway. So pretty similar. I'm pretty much the person I've always been, which I guess is quite comforting. Like I always knew I wanted to be a writer and I always knew I wanted to do like theater. So when I was a kid, I really wanted to write fiction. So I think it does feel like a childhood dream sort of discovered and kind of a welcome home in a way because that was always the
才找到？对，我当时想，有时候他们需要一段时间才能把它上架。我以前对书店一无所知。是的，这些都是经验。好的，这是我最近非常喜欢问大家的一个问题，那就是：既然你现在已经是一位内容创作者和作家了，你小时候的梦想职业是什么？这从一开始就是你的目标吗？我以前想当一名作家，还想去百老汇演出。所以其实挺相似的。我基本上还是我一直以来的那个人，我想这挺让人欣慰的。就像我一直都知道自己想成为一名作家，也一直知道自己想从事戏剧表演。所以当我还是个孩子的时候，我真的很想写小说。所以我觉得这确实像是一个被发掘的童年梦想，某种程度上有一种“欢迎回家”的感觉，因为那一直是我的。
dream. And obviously went down a different path first and I feel really grateful for that path as well. But fiction was definitely always like where my head was at when I was younger. Did you feel like there was a point in your life where you were like maybe this isn't going to happen? Like maybe this is just not for me. No. I honestly thought to myself if I don't make it, like it's going to be the love of my life forever either way. Like if I don't make it, I'm always going to write and I'll self-publish. If I don't make it with Broadway, like, I'll do what I can to make enough money that I could
梦想。当然，我最初走了一条不同的路，我也为那条路感到非常庆幸。但当我年轻的时候，我的脑子里绝对一直都是关于小说的。你觉得在你的人生中，有没有某个时刻让你觉得，也许这件事不会发生了？比如，也许这根本不适合我？没有。我当时真心实觉得，如果我没有成功，它也依然会成为我一生的挚爱，无论如何都是。就像如果我没有成功，我也会一直写作，我会选择自费出版。如果我在百老汇没有成功，我会尽我所能去赚足够的钱，好让我能。
like donate to Broadway shows or like donate to children's theater. Like I just knew I would always be involved in the arts. even if I didn't make it. So, like, no, I knew that no matter why I would still do it. Like, no one can take writing away from you. Like, if you can't publish traditionally, which would be like the dream, the dream, the dream, the dream, like, you can publish yourself. And if you don't, like, anyone could do that.
够捐助百老汇演出，或者捐助儿童戏剧。我只知道，我会永远参与艺术事业，即使我没有成功。所以，没有，我知道无论如何我都会继续做下去。就像，没有人能剥夺你写作的权力。如果你不能通过传统渠道出版——这本该是终极梦想、终极梦想、终极梦想——你可以自己出版。如果你不这么做，任何人都做得到。就像我做的那样。当我还在上大学的时候，我就自费出版了一本诗集。我想我当时只是知道，无论如何，即使我没有成功，没有人能把创作这件事从我身边拿走。它已经成了我的一种习惯，融入了我的血液，是我每天都会做的事。
Like, I did it. And when I was in college, I self-published a poetry book. Like, I think I just knew that, like, no matter what, if I didn't make it, like, no one could take doing it away from me. It was habitual, like, in my blood every day, something I did. and same with theater. Like no one can take being a fan of the arts away from you. No one can take being an audience member away from you.
戏剧也是如此。没有人能剥夺你作为一个艺术爱好者的权利。没有人能剥夺你作为一个观众的权利。所以真的从来没有哪个时刻让我觉得这可能不会发生，因为我知道，即使我在传统意义上没有取得成功，它依然会是我生活的一部分。这就足够了。我觉得其他的一切都只是锦上添花。不，我完全同意你的看法。作为另一个非常切实地在过着自己长期梦想的生活的人，我也深有同感。人们总是会问：“我怎么知道什么是我的。”
So there was really never a moment that I was like this might not happen because I knew that even if I didn't make it in the traditional sense of the term, like it would still be part of my life. And that was enough for me. I think everything else is just like a cherry on top. No, so I totally agree with you. And I feel this as someone else who is like very much living out a dream they had for a long time. People always are like, how do I know what like my,
梦想工作呢？我怎么知道我该做什么？我怎么知道我的人生目标是什么？而我的回答是：如果你即使没有任何报酬也愿意去做这件事，那么你最爱做、单纯因为喜欢才去做、甚至实际上根本不需要报酬也依然会充满热情的事到底是什么？这才是最关键的。有些人可能无法从这些事情中赚到钱，对吧？但这并不意味着它就不是你的人生目标。重要。是的。是的，而且同样重要。你怎么看“对自己的梦想保持盲目自信/执着”这件事？你对这种追求自己想要的东西的方法有什么看法？我觉得必须得有一点点盲目自信。我觉得没有人会真正、自信地相信自己可以走出去，
dream job is. Like how do I know what I meant to be doing? How do I know what my purpose is? And I'm like, if you would be doing it even if there was no one paying attention, what is the thing you do that you just love to do because you love to do it, that you wouldn't actually ever need to be paid for and you would still have the love for. Like that's the biggest thing. And some people like can't make money off of those things, right? That doesn't mean it's not still like your purpose. Important. Yeah. Yeah. And not still important. What do you think about being delusional about your dreams? What are your thoughts on like this, this method for going after what you want? I think there has to be like a bit of delusion. Like I don't think anybody like truly like confidently believes that they can like go out and
然后把一切都收入囊中。我是说，也许有人会吧。我觉得必须把现实主义和盲目自信健康地结合起来。现实主义就是那个现实的声音，告诉你这些是，你知道的，这就是现实，这就是我们目前所处的状态。现在。然后你还得把这种心态提升到一个额外的水平，那就是在并行的同时去相信自己。所以我认为你必须有一点盲目自信，也必须有一点现实主义。这就是我脑海中一直停留的状态。我不是完全活在幻想中，但我也确实有一点点盲目自信，你知道的，我会保留。我会保留那么一点点盲目自信。但我尽量对自己保持现实。我觉得这帮我保持了脚踏实地。我总是谈论我的。
snatch everything. I mean, maybe people do. I think there has to be a healthy mix of like realism and delusion. So the realism is like just that realistic voice being like these are, you know, this is reality and this is where we're at. right now. And then you have to sort of also take it the extra level that you just believe in yourself in tandem. So I think you have to have a little delusion and a little realism. That's always where I've like rested in my head. I'm not like totally delusional, but I'm also like a little delusional, you know, like I'll keep it. I'll keep it a little delusional. But I try to be realistic with myself. Like I think it just helped me be grounded. I always talk about like how my
父母是怎么把我们抚养长大的。我们从小受到的教育是，除非我们付出了努力，否则不应该得到掌声。我的父母不是那种类型的。哦，他们只是嫉妒你。我的父母不是那种会说“你太完美了”的人。我的父母很爱我们。但如果我们某件事做得不好，他们是不会告诉我们说我们做得很棒的。你知道我的意思吗？我们需要通过努力来赢得掌声。我认为这教会了我很好地认识自己的长处，并学会如何弥补自己的短处。我很擅长保持真实。然后我觉得盲目自信的地方就在于，当你想要做巨大的梦时，你必须有点古怪，你必须相信自己能够做到。有时候这需要你在某种程度上自我欺骗一下。但我尽量做到尽可能现实，同时又带有一点盲目自信。
parents raised us. Like, we were never raised to like get applause unless we earned it. Like my parents were not the type of people. Oh, they're just jealous of you. My parents were not like you're perfect. My parents loved us. But like if we weren't good at something, we were not being told we were good at it. You know what I mean? Like we were getting we had to earn applause from things. And I think that it taught me like to understand my strengths and learn how to work on my weaknesses in a really good way. Like I'm good at being real. And then I think the delusion comes in with like, You just have to be a little wacky when you're going to dream really big and you have to believe that you can. And sometimes that takes like kind of kidding yourself in a way. But I try to be as
你看，我有另一个毛病，我觉得有时我太现实了，因为我觉得盲目自信会带来厄运或诅咒。我不知道你是否有类似的感觉，有时我会想，如果我想象过某件事发生，并且如果我真的非常希望它发生，有时我会担心这会带来厄运，这意味着在某个宇宙中它已经发生了。所以它将永远不会被允许再次出现。你对此有什么看法？是的，我能理解那种感觉。我，是的，我觉得在经历那些我没有得到、但我其实依然有资格再次争取的事情时——比如奖项、提名、畅销书，这或那——我只是意识到。
realistic as possible and then also a little delusional. See, I have this other problem where I feel like sometimes I'm a little bit too realistic because I feel like being delusional jinxed things. I don't know if you have this similar feeling where sometimes I'm like if I've thought about something happening and if I really want it to happen, sometimes I get worried that it's going to like jinx it and going to mean that in some universe it's already happened. So like it's never going to be allowed to emerge again. What do your thoughts on? Yeah, I feel that. I, yeah, I think that like in going through processes for things I didn't get, but like that I'm still qualified to get again, like awards or nominations or bestseller, this or that, like I've just realized that. Like,
把这么大的压力压在一件事情上根本不值得，因为那样的话，你的感受会变成：哦，是我自己墨菲定律让它没能发生的。所以我尽量只管做到最好，其余的随缘。我尽量不去想那些榜单、荣誉，以及所有我知道正在酝酿中、正在考虑我、或者曾经考虑过我的事情——我尽量把它们全忘掉。就好像它们对我不存在一样。这样一来，我就只能专注于作品本身。我不去关注数字、数据之类的事情。
placing all this pressure on a thing is just not worth it because then you'll feel like how you feel like, oh, I manifested this not happening. So I try to just do my best and like forget the rest. Like I try not to think about the lists and the accolades and all the things that I know are like around the bend that I'm being considered for that I have been considered for. Like I try to just forget it all. Like it doesn't exist to me. And so that way like I'm only focusing on the work. And I don't focus on like, you know, numbers and data and this and that.
当然，这些事情确实很重要。这也是我关注的一部分。但我尽量让自己保持脚踏实地，专注于创作本身、创作的行为以及艺术本身，而不要过多地关注外界。因为我觉得当我过度关注外界时，我会感到非常失望。我也会有和你一样的感觉，觉得“哦，是我自己导致了它没有发生”。是的，真的，真的太对了。我觉得这是我一直希望自己能听到的建议。
And then of course like those things do matter. And there are things that I focus on. but I try to keep myself like pretty grounded in just like the creative, the act of creating and then the art itself and not so much on the external. Because I think when I did that, I would get really disappointed. And I would also like feel like you did where it would be like, oh, I manifested this not happening. Yeah, no, very, very true. I feel like this is the advice that I wish I could.
我依然觉得我自己需要听到这个建议，那就是：纯粹为了纯粹的快乐去做一件事。纯粹为了快乐去做这件事。然后没有人能真正把它从你身边拿走。我想，这就是我们作为在创意领域和娱乐行业工作的人，一次又一次回到的核心主旨。我在这里稍微转换一下话题，我们来聊聊我们的二十多岁，因为我觉得收听节目的听众正是处于这个年纪。
I still think I need to hear myself, which is like just do it for the joy of doing something. Like just do it for the joy. and then no one can ever really take that away from you, which is, I guess, like, the through line that we've just been coming back to, like, time and time again as people who are, like, working in creative spaces and working in, like, in entertainment. I'm kind of going to shift gears here, and let's talk a bit about our 20s, because I feel like that's what people are tuning in from.
你显然有很多你真正关心、非常想做的事情。我觉得大家在这个十年里遇到的一个重大困惑是：我真的有太多东西想要尝试了，我想去实现，我想去见识，那我该如何同时把它们都做到呢？所以这可能是一个奇怪的问题，但比如说，你的时间管理策略是什么，时间管理建议是什么，或者关于“试图同时做好所有事情”这方面，你有没有什么更深层的想法？
Yeah. You obviously have a lot of things that you really care about and that you really want to do. And I think a big dilemma that people have in this decade is, there is literally so much that I want to try. and I want to achieve and I want to see how do I do it all at once? So this may be like a strange question, but like, what are your time management strategies, time management advice, or like maybe deeper thoughts on like, yeah, I guess trying to do it all at once?
每当我听到人们发出这种抱怨，说有那么多想过的人生、那么多想尝试的事物时，我的反应是：天呐，这是何等的特权啊。你需要重新定义这种心态。对于有那么多想尝试的事情从而对生活充满激情，这是何等的特权啊。对于对生活如此着迷、有那么多想做的事情，这是何等的特权啊。对我来说，现实情况是——而且这是我们完全无法改变的——你永远不可能尝试所有的事情。你可能永远无法访问每一个地方，也无法读完每一本书。
I think when I hear people have that sort of complaint of like there's so many lives they want to live and so many things that I want to try, I'm like, God, what a privilege. Like you need to reframe it. like what a privilege to be so excited to live that there are so many things you want to try. What a privilege to be so like enamored with life that there are so many things you want to do. Like to me the reality is and it's completely something we can't change. You're never going to be able to try everything. You're never going to be able to probably visit every place or read every book.
但能够尽可能多地去看看不同的地方，或者读尽可能多的书，或者尝试尽可能多的事情，这是一件多么美好的礼物啊。有太多人根本没有这种奢侈。有太多人出生在没有这种奢侈的境况中，或者出生时身体不健全。我只是努力让自己深深扎根于这种现实中：能够对尝试事物感到兴奋、能够去尝试事物，这是一种特权。我经常和朋友们谈论这样一个事实：我觉得在你的二十多岁，你必须选择一件事作为你世界的核心焦点，而这件事可以从一个章节到另一个章节、从一年到另一年、甚至从一个月到另一个月发生变化。而我基本上选择了我的工作。它处于我世界的中心。
But like what a gift that you could try to see as many places as possible or like read as many books as possible or try as many things as possible. Like there are so many people that just don't have that. luxury. There are so many people that are born into circumstances where they don't have that luxury or are born or not able body. Like I just try to be so grounded in the reality of the privilege it is to be excited to try things and to get to try things. And then I have so often talked with my friends about the fact that I think like in your 20s, you kind of have to pick something to be like the center focus point of your world and that thing can change from chapter to chapter year to year, even month to month. And like I've sort of picked my job. Like it's at the center of
我做出了牺牲。其他一切我都牺牲了。为了我的工作，我做出了太多的牺牲。对某些人来说，他们想选择友谊。对某些人来说，他们想选择他们所处的社群。对某些人来说，他们选择家庭或浪漫关系。我也认为处于中心的那件事是可以改变的。它在任何给定的星期或任何给定的月份都可能改变。我的意思是，我知道通过把我的工作和职业生涯作为当前的中心焦点，我正在做出牺牲。我并不总能参加社交活动。我其实不怎么出门，因为我必须休息，因为我在工作上投入了太多精力。
my world. I sacrifice. Everything else I sacrifice. I make so many sacrifices for my work. For some people, they want to choose their friendships. For some people, they want to choose a community that they're a part of. For some people, they choose family or a romantic relationship. I also think that that thing at the center can change. It could change it any given week or any given month. What I mean by this is like, I know that by putting my job and my career right now as the center focal point, I am sacrificing things. I can't always make it to social outings. I don't really go out because I have to rest because I'm, you know, extending. myself so much with my work, but that's something I have to be okay with. So I think you have to
我的精力严重透支，但这是我必须接受的事情。所以我认为你必须弄清楚你的优先级是什么，弄清楚任何一个月或星期的中心点将是什么，然后接受你必须设定的界限，以及为了专注于此你必须做出的牺牲。然后我认为与此同时，要意识到被选择淹没、对生活感到兴奋是一种特权；是的，你可以选择很多条路径。是的，确实存在决策疲劳。我经常有这种感觉。但这就好像：被选择的机会折腾到精疲力竭是一件多么美妙的礼物啊，许多人甚至都无法拥有这种体验。
make, you have to figure out what your priorities are, figure out what the center point is going to be of any month or any week, and then be okay with the boundaries you have to set and the sacrifices you have to make in order to focus on that. And then I think kind of simultaneously, just like realize it's a privilege to be overwhelmed with choice and to be excited about life. Like, yes, there are so many paths that you could take. And yes, there is a such thing as decision fatigue. Like I so often feel that way. But it's like what a gift it is to be so exhausted by the opportunity to choose something so many people cannot say that they have.
我太喜欢这种思维方式了。我也很喜欢这种延伸思考：如果把这个想法再推进一步，那就意味着你随时可以重新选择，对吧？如果你有那么多感觉同样美好的选择，这就意味着你其实永远不会被困在某个单一的选择中。是的。你会永远觉得“哦，我走错了路”，因为如果你真的觉得有那么多选项的话，总会有别的东西在等着你，你知道我的意思吗？是的，而且人们
I love that way of thinking about it. And I also love that if you go even further with that thought, that means that like you can always choose again, right? If you have so many choices that feel equally good, it means that like you're actually probably never going to be stuck in one choice. Yeah. Like you'll never feel, oh, I took the wrong path because like there's always going to be something else waiting for you if you really do feel like there are so many options you know what i mean yeah and people
每一天都在改变自己的生活。我觉得人们之所以如此执着于“我想过什么样的生活”，是因为他们认为这就像他们与世界或其他人签署的某种合同，如果我说我要做这个，这就是我要成为的人，我必须准备好把十年的生命奉献给它。没有人要求你这么做——在任何时候，任何给定的时间，你都被允许改变主意。就选择一件事作为起点而言，你有没有问过自己什么问题，或者你会问朋友什么问题，来帮助他们确定“这是我应该做的第一件事”？我想大概是：你想做什么？我觉得人们没有，我觉得人们
change their lives like every single day i feel like the reason that people get so like fixated on like what life do i want to live is because they think that it's like some kind of contract that they're signing with like the world or with other people that like if i say i'm going to do this and this is who i'm going to be i have to be ready to give 10 years of my life to that no one's asking you to do that like you are allowed to change your mind like at any, any given time. In terms of choosing one thing just to start, were there any, like, are there any questions that you were able to ask yourself or that you would ask a friend to help them determine, like, which is the first thing I should do? I guess it's just like, what do you want to do? Like, I think that people don't, I think that people
把事情想得太复杂了。你想做什么？如果社交媒体不存在，也没有其他人意见的干扰。你想做什么？好吧，那就去做。我觉得人们总是把事情搞得太复杂。归根结底，在成年后我意识到，选择会极大泛滥。你需要与自己建立极好的联系，才能问自己：我想做什么？我想穿什么？我想和谁共度时光？你必须摸索出如何足够了解自己，从而回答这些问题。我觉得有时我们根本没有问自己这个问题，因为我们太纠结于其他人了。这就好像，不对，你自己到底想要什么？那才是关键。
way over-complicate things. Like, what do you want to do? Like, if social media didn't exist and nobody else's opinion mattered. What do you want to do? Like, okay, then do that. Like, that, I think people way overcomplicate things. Like, at the end of the day, in adulthood, I've realized, like, there's going to be such a proliferation of choice. And you need to get super in touch with yourself to be able to ask yourself, what do I want to do? What do I want to wear? Who do I want to spend my time around? And you have to figure out how to know yourself well enough to answer those questions. I feel like sometimes we're just not asking ourselves that question because we're so caught up in everybody else and it's like no but what do you want like that's what
你究竟想要什么？我觉得人们没有这样问过自己，而且通常也没有人这样问他们。是的，大家总是在问：你打算怎么赚钱？你打算怎么实现我对你的期望？你打算怎么获得幸福？这是另一个人们总是纠结的问题，就好像：我怎么知道我会不会快乐？而事实是，根本没有这样的保证。其实我前几天才跟我姐姐聊过这个，如果你同意我这种提问方式，不妨告诉我。有时候人们会——我想我告诉你我总是怎么问她的。我说，判断你想过什么样生活的最简单方法，就是看看你在嫉妒谁。看看谁把他们的生活梦想活成了那种
what do you actually want and i feel like people aren't asking themselves that and they're often not asked that either yeah it's always like how are you going to make money like how are you going to fulfill this dream that i have for you like how are you going to be happy that's the other question i feel like people always get fixated on it's like how do i know i'll be happy it's like no one there is no promise something i actually i was talking to my sister about this the other day and tell me if you agree with this line of questioning and sometimes people like I think I'll tell you what I always ask her I say like the easiest way to determine what kind of life you want is to is to see who you're jealous of see who is like lived out their dreams in like such a
如此惊艳的模样，以至于你唯一能理解自己可能也想要这种生活的方式，就是通过嫉妒，因为你太渴望它了。很多人们听到我这么说时会说：“哇，你在宣扬嫉妒情绪。”而我会说：“不，因为嫉妒其实包含两种情绪，对吧？”它其实是一个双层的东西。首先是初始的感受，其次是你如何对此做出反应。你不需要以一种背后捅刀子、糟糕透顶、自我贬低的方式做出反应。你可以用一种相当具有激励性的方式做出反应，实际上是将它转化为灵感和庆祝。你对这个观点有什么看法？因为我知道有些人听到这个会有完全不同的看法。
such an amazing way that the only way that you can like comprehend that you might want it is through envy because like you want it so badly and a lot of people are like when I when I tell them that are like wow, you're promoting being jealous. And I'm like, no, because jealousy is actually like two emotions, right? It's actually, it's a two-layered thing. There's the initial feeling and then there's how you react to it. You don't have to react in like a backstabbing, terrible, self-effacing way. You can react in a way that, like, makes it quite motivating and actually, like, switches to inspiration and celebration. What are your thoughts on that? Because I know some people like hear that and, like, have a completely different take.
我真的很喜欢这个观点。我觉得这是一个超级真实的观点。我绝对是那种认为嫉妒其实并不是什么坏事的人。我觉得我们只是把它妖魔化了。但我总是说，这是一个信号，表明别人拥有你想要的东西。你完全可以不必去想“天哪，为什么是他们而不是我”，而是同样可以去想“为什么我们不能两个都拥有”或者“为什么我也不能拥有那个东西”。所以我觉得嫉妒，是的，我觉得这是一种超级正常的人类情感，我们应该更坦然地去面对和正视它。而且它也是一种相当有帮助的情感。好的，我们要稍作休息，但回来后，我们将讨论比较、如何应对别人对你的误解，以及如何在二十多岁时处理友谊。所以请继续收听。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及构建抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，
I really like that. I think that's like super true point. I'm definitely someone who thinks that jealousy is like not really a bad thing. Like I just think like we've villainized it ourselves. But like I always say it's a signal that somebody else has something that you want. And instead of being like, oh, why them and not me? You could just as easily be like, why not us both? Or like, why can't I have that thing too? So I think jealousy is yeah, I think it's a super normal human emotion that we have to be like more comfortable kind of. confronting and facing. And it's also quite a helpful one as well. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to talk about comparison, how to manage when people have the wrong idea of you, and how to deal with friendship in our 20s. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
以此看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个。更快乐、更 fulfilled（充实）、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，在I-Heart Radio应用程序、
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Heart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（捏）小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的“快克”毒品。澄清一下，84年对我的意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当年快克的事，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，到目前为止，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆到台面上来了。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某种事物的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们仍在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。达斯汀·罗斯、史蒂夫·伯恩斯，因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
你是一个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标的真实对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战。来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle. to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either.
我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》这一新季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？警察似乎根本不在乎。所以，她们决定自己采取行动。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So, they take matters into their own hands.
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我要做他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们来聊聊比较，特别是艺术领域的比较。我实际上想问你的第一个问题是完全无关的。但是，当人们称你为“网红（influencer）”时，你对这个词有什么看法？你更愿意别人称你为作家、内容创作者，还是网红？你对这个词是怎么看的？
Let's talk about comparison, specifically like comparison in the arts. First question, I actually have for you, which is completely unrelated. But what do you think about the term when people call you an influencer? would you prefer like someone call you an author, a content creator, an influencer? What do you like kind of think about that word?
我倒不一定讨厌这个词。我觉得很悲哀的是，这个词不知怎么变成了一个贬义词，尤其是男性特意用来作为武器去攻击女性。所以，既然知道了这一点，反而让我有点更喜欢它了，因为我会想：你们怎么会把这个词当成侮辱呢？而这个词字面描述的明明是一个绝大多数由女性组成的经济体，她们通过自己的努力摆脱学生债务，为自己买房，为自己创造了她们以前从未拥有过的代际财富。你们怎么能把这个词用作。
I don't dislike it necessarily. I think it's so sad that it's become sort of like this derogatory term that men specifically utilized to weaponize it against women. So like, knowing that, it makes me kind of like it more because I'm like, how are you going to, how are you going to use this term as an insult? And this term literally describes an economy of mostly women who are like, pulling themselves out of student debt, buying themselves homes, creating generational wealth for themselves that they never had before. Like, how are you going to use that? Like,
侮辱呢，这简直有点脑残。所以我不介意。不管别人怎么称呼我，我都挺高兴的。当然，我希望人们能提到我的书，但对于所谓的“网红”身份我并不困扰，因为我承认它是一个实际可行且具备生存能力的职业。我觉得当人们问“哦，你是不是不想让我叫你网红？你对此有什么感觉？”时，这种提问背后其实源于一种人们不承认它是一份真正职业的心态。这让我感到非常难过，因为我觉得，哇，这是一个女性主导的行业，充满了女性在彻底重写自己的人生，并变得经济独立，
as though it's an insults, like, kind of screwed up. So I don't mind it. I'm happy with however anybody wants to credit me. Like, of course, I would love the books to be referenced, but, like, I'm not bothered by the influencer of it all because I recognize it as like an actual viable career. And I feel like when people say like, oh, do you not want me to call you an influencer? How do you feel about that? It comes from this place of like people don't recognize it as a real career. And that kind of makes me so sad because I'm like, wow, it's like this female dominated industry full of women like completely rewriting their own lives and becoming independently
这本该是值得庆祝的事。但出于某种原因，它并没有被庆祝。你看，这就是澳大利亚目前正在发生的对话——我们称之为网红的一群人，显然。在我们的近期的选举中进行政治报道，结果这个词被用来彻底贬低他们的观点，质问他们在这些环境中到底在干什么。但是，关于这个行业——这是一个价值数十亿美元的行业——的一点是，它也可能具有相当大的竞争性，并且存在着大量的……
wealthy, which like should be celebrated. But for some reason, it's not. See, this is the conversation that like is happening in Australia right now where like a bunch of what we would call influencers were, obviously. like doing political coverage for like our recent election and it was like used as such like this term to just like completely undercut their their opinions and to be like what are they doing like on in these in these environments um but like something about that industry and it is a multi-billion dollar industry um is that it can be like quite competitive as well and there is a lot of like
财富，这本该值得庆祝。但不知为何，事实并非如此。你看，这就是澳大利亚目前正在进行的对话，我们称之为网红的一群人，显然在为我们最近的选举做政治报道，这被用作一个贬低他们观点的词汇，质问他们在这种环境下在做什么。嗯，但这个行业有些特殊，这是一个价值数十亿美元的行业，那就是它也可能相当竞争激烈，而且有许多类似于
comparison and yeah like we said jealousy how do you How do you manage that? Or do you just like not experience it or utilize it in a different way? Yeah, I think it's like anything else. Like I'm sure people at their own nine to five jobs have the experience of like I even talk with my friends. Like you're competing against a coworker for a promotion. Like there's a lot of competition within those spaces. So I think it's like anything else that like you're going to compare yourself to people and you're going to see somebody on this brand trip getting this deal, shooting this. thing and you're going to say, why didn't I get that? But I think if you want to be successful, you can't, you can't view other content creators as competition only as community. And I genuinely feel that way. Like sometimes those creeping senses of comparison will creep up. But like,
比较，对，就像我们刚才说的，嫉妒，你该怎么，你该怎么处理？或者你只是不去经历它，还是以另一种方式利用它？对，我觉得这就像其他事情一样。比如，我确信朝九晚五上班的人也会有这样的体验，我甚至会和朋友聊起这个。比如你为了晋升在和同事竞争。在这些领域里存在着很多竞争。所以我觉得这就像其他任何事情一样，你会拿自己和别人做比较，你会看到某个人在这次品牌之旅中拿到了这笔合作，拍了这个。东西，然后你就会说，为什么我没有得到？但我觉得如果你想成功，你就不能，你不能把其他的创作者视为竞争对手，只能视他们为社区。我是真心这么觉得的。有时候那种潜滋暗长的比较心理会涌上心头。但是，
I know that like rising tides rise all boats. When one of us wins, we all win. And like, I believe that the opportunities meant for me won't pass me by. And so because I believe that, I try not to sit with any sort of comparison at all. And instead I'm like, that's my community. Like, look at how well people in my community are doing. Like, I see another influencer write a book. When I see an influencer launch a podcast, a book club, a show, anything that is similar to the stuff I do. Like, I'm just celebrating that because it's like when one person in our community wins, we all
我知道水涨船高。我们其中一个人赢了，我们就都赢了。而且，我相信属于我的机会是不会与我擦肩而过的。正因为我相信这一点，我尽量不去纠结于任何形式的比较。相反，我会觉得，那是我的社区。你看我的社区里的人做得多好。比如，我看到另一个网红写了一本书。当我看到一个网红推出播客、读书俱乐部、节目，或者任何与我所做的事情相似的东西时。我都在为之庆祝，因为这就像我们社区里的一个人赢了，我们所有人都会
win. And the more that we view it like that, just like the better it is for everybody. Yeah. And I feel like by talking about this like in a singular like business space, but that's like advice that you can take in any area that you're in in your 20s. Like especially academics as well. Like I feel like a lot of people. who listen to this are like still obviously still in university or some of them are even like in high
赢。我们越是以这种方式看待它，对每个人来说就越好。对。我觉得通过在一个单一的商业空间里谈论这件事，但这也是你在20岁时可以在任何领域采纳的建议。尤其是学术方面。我觉得很多人。听这个节目的，显然都还在上大学，或者其中有些人甚至还在高
school um and the thing is is that like comparison will continue to repeat itself oh it'll always exist yeah it will always exist and like you think that like oh i'm going to leave this like hyperacademic environment it's going to be gone no because it's like a human quality right so it's going to be with you you have to like just change how you approach it totally and i also think that like you're just going to continue to raise the standards that you have to upset for yourself. So it's like not going anywhere. You just have to learn how to maintain and manage it. Okay. So this is another kind of element of this that I think you probably deal with like in your career more than others, but which everyone is going to come across at some point in their
中。嗯，问题在于，比较会不断重复出现。哦，它会一直存在。是的，它会一直存在。而且你会觉得，哦，我要离开这个超级学术的环境了，它就会消失。不，因为这是一种人类的特质，对吧？所以它会一直伴随着你，你只需要改变你对待它的方式。完全是这样。而且我也觉得，你只会不断提高你为自己设定的标准。所以它不会消失。你只需要学会如何维持和管理它。好的。所以这是这件事的另一个方面，我觉得你在职业生涯中可能比其他人处理得更多，但每个人在某个时刻都会遇到。
lives, which is managing people having the wrong impression or opinion of you. And I actually saw you make like an Instagram story about this the other day, which was like, that's the worst part of this job is having the bravery to like be like, this is my life now comment on it however you would like and not being able to kind of talk back to those like, like, you know, false impressions. How do you manage that? I think you have to realize like there are people that are hell bent on misunderstanding you. Like whatever you say, they will be like, you're wrong. There are people that have a story about you in their mind.
那就是应对别人对你有错误的印象或意见。我实际上前几天看到你在Instagram上发了一条快拍，大概意思是，这份工作最糟糕的部分就是需要有勇气去说，这就是我的生活，你们想怎么评论就怎么评论吧，却无法去回击那些，像，你知道的，错误的印象。你是怎么处理这一点的？我觉得你必须意识到，总有些人铁了心要误解你。无论你说什么，他们都会觉得你是错的。有些人心里对你有一个固定的看法。
they mine for details to confirm that story is true. The story is riddled with confirmation bias. And it's like, I don't want to focus on that 1% of people. If I could focus on the 99% of people who know my heart and my person and who I am. So I just ignore it. I think it takes a lot of strength to get to that place. And I don't think it's for everyone.
他们搜寻细节来证明那个故事是真的。这个故事充满了确认偏误。我觉得，我不想把注意力放在那1%的人身上。如果我能把注意力放在那99%了解我的内心、了解我这个人、知道我是谁的人身上。所以我选择无视它。我觉得要达到那种境界需要很大的力量。而且我觉得这并不适合所有人。
Like I have a lot of friends who are like, I would love to post, but like I could never deal with the perception aspect. And I get that. Like, it's not for everyone. And that's not to say I'm like stronger than anyone else. It's just a matter of do you want to deal with it yes or no. I do believe anyone could get to a place where they're dealing with it in a healthy way,
比如我有很多朋友说，我很想发动态，但我绝对无法应付别人看法的方面。我理解这一点。这并不适合所有人。这并不是说我比其他人更坚强。这只关乎你是否想去应对它，是还是否。我相信任何人都能达到以健康方式应对它的地步，
but not everybody wants to, which is totally valid. And I get. And I wouldn't recommend it. Like, I, I wouldn't recommend it because it takes a lot of mental strength to get to a place where you can just read like nasty lies about yourself and you have to, you can't do anything about it. Like you, there's zero you could do. If you try to, if you, if someone said, she had a nose job and you never had a nose job,
但不是每个人都想这么做，这完全可以理解。我懂。而且我不会推荐这样做。比如，我，我不会推荐这样做，因为要达到一种境界，能够直面关于你自己的恶劣谎言却无能为力，这需要极大的心理力量。就像你，你对此无能为力。如果你试图去，如果有人说，她做了鼻整形手术，而你从来没做过鼻整形手术，
so you went on a lie detector test and said, I never had a nose job. And it said you were telling the truth. they would be like she paid off the lie detector like if they believed that you had a nose job even if you never did they're never not going to believe that so like there's nothing that you can do and once you just free yourself from the idea that like people are just going to be hell been on having the wrong idea of you why would you focus on anyone who has the wrong idea about you like you know the truth like it really brings me a piece to know i've never had a nose job you know what i mean i mean i mean that's just an example no one's ever said that about me but like that's my example like i've never had a
所以你去做测谎仪测试，并说，我从来没做过鼻整形手术。测谎仪显示你在说实话。他们会说她收买测谎仪了——如果他们认定你做过鼻子，哪怕你从来没做过，他们也永远不会相信你不是那样的。所以你对此无能为力。一旦你从这种想法中解放出来——即人们铁了心对你抱有错误的看法——你为什么还要去关注任何对你有错误看法的人呢？你自己知道真相。知道自己从来没做过鼻整形手术，真的能带给我内心平静，你知道我的意思吗？我是说，我的意思是这只是个例子，从来没有人对我说过这样的话。但这就是我的例子——我从来没做过
knows job and if you know that about yourself why shouldn't matter that people are spending a falsified story about the fact that you had one you know what I mean yeah I do and I feel like it's this whole everything we've been talking about here like relies on the fact that we get so much about identity and validation and sense of self-worth from like our social ties and so when we are misunderstood when we feel jealous when we feel comparison it kind of fractures that like foundation for our beliefs this is just like another battle for this what's like the worst misunderstanding that you've heard about yourself. Like I have one, but like of my, of my own.
鼻整形手术。如果你自己知道这一点，为什么要在乎别人散布关于你做过手术的虚假故事呢？你知道我的意思吗？是的，我懂。而且我觉得这一切——我们在这里谈论的所有事情——都建立在一个事实之上，即我们的身份认同、认可感和自我价值感很大程度上来自于我们的社交联系。所以当我们被误解时，当我们感到嫉妒时，当我们进行比较时，这有点动摇了我们信念的基础。这只是对此的另一场战斗。关于你自己的，你听过最糟糕的误解是什么？我有一个，但关于我自己的。
And I feel like each of us has this thing that like we have been misunderstood about that we wish we could like clarify. What's yours? People always like have said that like my parents paid for my book deals, which like I don't understand how people can't wrap their head around this. Like you cannot pay a traditional publisher to publish your book. You cannot pay Simon & Schuster, Hachette, Harper Collins. like a penguin, you cannot pay them.
我觉得我们每个人都有这样一件事，一件我们被误解、希望能澄清的事。你的是什么？人们总是说我父母为我的书约支付了费用，这让我无法理解人们怎么就转不过这个弯来。你不可能花钱请传统出版商来出版你的书。你不能花钱请西蒙与舒斯特、阿歇特、哈珀柯林斯。比如企鹅，你不能付钱给他们。
That's not a thing. It doesn't exist. There's no amount of money in the world that they will take to publish your book. Like, you can't do that. So that frustrates me because I feel like it just undermines like what I was able to do for myself. People say my parents connected me to them. My parents work in restaurants.
这不是那么回事。它根本不存在。世界上没有哪笔钱能让他们拿来帮你出书。比如，你做不到这一点。所以这让我很沮丧，因为我觉得这简直贬低了我凭自己能力所做到的事情。人们说我的父母把我引荐给他们的。我的父母在餐馆工作。
They own small family run businesses. One time, my dad self-published a coffee table book about food. Like, that was a self-publication. You can go and do it on Amazon. You can pay someone to self-published. publish a book. My parents don't have connections in publishing. If they did, I never would have went into student debt to go to grad school. I would have said, mom and dad hook me up with your connections. Like, they don't have them. And if they did, like, I'm so honest about so many things
他们拥有小型家族经营企业。有一次，我爸爸自费出版了一本关于食物的咖啡桌书。那是一本自费出版的书。你可以去亚马逊上做这件事。你可以花钱让人自费出版一本书。我的父母在出版界没有任何人脉。如果有的话，我当年绝不会背负学生贷款去读研究生。我会说，爸爸妈妈，用你们的人脉帮帮我吧。他们没有。如果有的话，而且我对生活中发生的那么多事情都如此诚实，
that happened in my life, I would share my connections. Like, I would say I had them, but I didn't have them. So it frustrates and upsets me that that allegation comes my way a lot. Um, because I'm like, damn. And then, yeah, of course, the, her parents pay for everything, which is just simply untrue. And I think that like a lot of people like I grew up very privileged. And the truth of the matter is my parents themselves did not grow up privileged. Like the life that they've given to myself and my brothers was very different from the lives that they had themselves. And so it brings me a lot of sadness to like see people that work so hard get sort of that tossed in their face because it's like they've worked so hard for my my brothers and I. But
我会分享我的人脉。我会说我有，但我没有。所以这种指控经常落到我头上，这让我感到沮丧和难过。嗯，因为我想，天哪。然后，是的，当然，还有“她的父母为一切买单”，这简直完全是无稽之谈。我觉得很多人，就像我是在极其优渥的环境中长大的。但事实的真相是，我的父母他们自己并不是在优渥的环境中长大的。他们给我和我的兄弟们的生活，与他们自己曾经的生活有着天壤之别。所以，看到那些努力工作的人却要面对这种指责，这让我感到非常难过，因为他们为我和兄弟们付出了那么多努力。但是
also I was cut off the day I graduated college. I am so transparent about how privileged that I have been in my life that I did not have student debt from my undergrad, which is like an unbelievable massive privilege that sets me up to be like miles ahead of other people. And I understand that truly and deeply. But I think it upsets me to see, oh, her parents pay for her whole life because like I'm so proud of myself. And also like my parents didn't come from what they were able to provide from us for us. So I think it also like, I don't know, it just makes me feel upset like they didn't instill a work ethic in me or that like they're just paying for me, which they're not. And I don't know. I think that that can be frustrating. And it's something that's levied at a lot of
与此同时，我大学毕业的那天就被断了经济来源。对于我这一生所享受过的优越条件，我是如此坦诚，我上本科时没有背负学生贷款，这是一种难以置信的巨大特权，它让我比其他人领先了无数个身位。我对此有着真实而深刻的理解。但我觉得看到“哦，她的父母为她包办了一切”这种言论让我很难过，因为我为自己感到骄傲。而且，我的父母并不是从他们自己曾经拥有的那种环境中为我们提供这一切的。所以我觉得这也，我不知道，这只是让我感到难过，仿佛他们没有在我身上培养出一种职业道德，或者仿佛他们只是在养着我，而事实并非如此。我不知道。我觉得这会让人感到沮丧。这也是许多
women who don't come from privilege as well, which I'm just like, that's just plain sexist. I guess I could see how people are arriving at the point that my parents like bankroll my life. But like I haven't taken a dime from them since I graduated college. I would go on a lie detector test. I wish I could. Those are some of them, like that I get that it's just frustrating. And like, I don't really need to prove people wrong because I don't really care. You couldn't believe my parents pay for my life and that they bought my book deals and that they connected me with everybody. But like, that was true. I would be, I would have been a published author at like 18. Literally, exactly. No, and I would have been calling that that contact up at like 16.
同样出身平凡的女性经常遭受的指责，对此我只想说，这纯粹是性别歧视。我想我能理解为什么人们会得出我父母资助我生活的结论。但我自从大学毕业以后，就没从他们那里拿过一分钱。我可以去测谎仪上接受测试。我希望我能去。其中有些就是这样，我懂，只是觉得很沮丧。而且，我其实不需要向人们证明他们是错的，因为我根本不在乎。你可以相信我父母为我的生活买单，相信他们买下了我的书约，相信他们把我介绍给了所有人。但如果那是真的，我早就在18岁左右成为畅销书作家了。字面意思，完全如此。不，我甚至会在16岁左右就给那个联系人打电话了。
Yeah. You would have been transferring the money into the bank accounts. Let's go. Like, yeah, like, I would have been bang for it myself. It's so frustrating. That's frustrating to me. And like, you know, there are worse things like in the world than that. But that's one of them that I'm always like, dang. Like I wish that like people just believe that I could work hard and obviously privilege has so much to do with it.
对。你会把钱转进银行账户里。走起。就像，是的，就像，我会自己付钱的。太令人沮丧了。这让我感到沮丧。而且，你知道，世界上比这糟糕的事情多得是。但这是其中一件总是让我觉得，天哪。我真希望人们只是相信我能努力工作，当然，特权在其中发挥了很大作用。
And I never want to shy away from that fact. Like the privilege I've had is undoubtedly set me ahead and allowed me to achieve the things I've achieved at such a young age. And that's not what I'm trying to suggest. I'm just trying to suggest when people like blatantly make up lies about me. It can be frustrating. I think it's also frustrating because it obviously like are things that go so deeply against your value set. Like I'm sure people have a lot of things that you could easily dismiss and be like, no.
我从不愿回避这个事实。我所拥有的特权无疑让我领先了一步，并让我在如此年轻的时候取得了所取得的成就。这并不是我想表达的。我只是想表达，当人们公然编造关于我的谎言时。这可能会令人沮丧。我觉得这也令人沮丧，因为这些显然是完全违背你的价值观的事情。我确信人们有很多你可以轻易驳回并说“不”的事情。
But it's when something is like so deep actually against your core values and who you are as a person. Yeah, exactly. Because I'd be honest. Like if I think it's so, I always see those memes of like when you find out your friend's parents are paying for their rent, but they like lie about it and stuff like that. like if my parents were paying for anything, I would be so open about that because I think like transparency in that regard is so important in our 20s, especially around money, money's so awkward.
但当某些事情如此深刻地违背了你的核心价值观以及你作为一个人的本质时。是的，exactly。因为我说实话。就像我觉得太，我总是看到那种梗图，讲的是当你发现你朋友的父母在帮他们付房租，但他们却对此撒谎之类的。如果我的父母在帮我付任何费用，我会非常公开地谈论这件事，因为我认为在20岁时这种透明度非常重要，尤其是在金钱方面，谈钱真的很尴尬。
And I would like to your point about it going against my value set, like if my parents connected me with somebody in the publishing world, I would also be honest about that because then my story would be a lie. The story of like how I got to where I am today would be just a total lie. And like that's so problematic and unfortunate, you know? Yeah, exactly. And also it's like it just would. be smart business. It just wouldn't be smart business. Yeah. Like if you, if you, if you believe
正如你所说，这违背了我的价值观，如果我的父母把我引荐给出版界的人，我也会对此诚实，因为那样的话我的故事就是假的。我如何走到今天的这个故事就会变成一个彻头彻尾的谎言。这不是很成问题且令人遗憾吗？是的，完全如此。而且这也是，这只是明智的商业决策。这本来就不是明智的商业决策。对。如果你，如果你，如果你别的都不信，你可以相信你会做对你的生意和你的身份最有利的事情。愚蠢的谎言。对，完全如此。就像，等一下。这就像对你父母是“星二代”这件事撒谎一样。就好像“星二代”们会说，我不是星二代。我为这一切付出了巨大的努力。人们并不是对星二代感到愤怒。他们愤怒的是当事人不承认自己占了起跑线上的便宜。你知道我的意思吗？不，我懂。就像那样。
nothing else, like you can believe that you would be doing what's best for your business and for like your identity. Dumb lie. That's a yeah, exactly. Exactly. It's like, wait. It's like lying about like your parents being Nepo baby. Like to be like when Nepo babies, they're like, I'm not a nepo baby. I've worked so hard for this. Like people aren't pissed about nepo babies. They're pissed when they don't admit that they had a leg up. You know what I mean? No, I know. It's like that.
我不知道你认不认识喜剧演员罗比·霍夫曼。我觉得我在播客里一直在谈论她。她太有趣了。她真的太有趣了。对，被严重低估了。她演过《绝望骗局》（Hacks），演过《为性垂死》（Dying for Sex），
I don't know if you know the comedian, Robbie Hoffman. I feel like I talk about her on the podcast all the time. She's so funny. She is so funny. Yeah, so underrated. Like she was on hacks, like she was on dying for sex,
两部非常棒的剧集。我觉得播客的忠实听众们可能都厌倦了我一直在谈论她有多优秀，但她接受了《Natsur》节目中瑞文的采访，就是瑞文。痴迷。她说，我不在乎你有没有钱。我想要钱。这就是为什么人们会在乎，但不要撒谎。我们并不是希望你变穷。我们只是也想变有钱，并且希望你诚实。这非常非常有趣，因为我记得我曾在墨尔本的一所市中心公立学校上学，
two really amazing shows. I feel like if the frequent listeners of the podcast is sick of me talking about how good she is, but she did this interview with Raven from Natsur, so Raven. Obsessed. And she was like, I don't care if you have money. I want the money. Like that's why like people care about it, but don't lie about it. Like we don't want you to be poor. We just also want to be rich and we want you to be honest. And like it and it was, it's very, very interesting because like I remember I went to this like inner city public school in like Melbourne
那里的每个人，或者说绝大多数人，都住在极其富裕的地区。没有人真正承认他们可能得到过一些接济，或者其实他们过得相当不错。这里有一种文化，就是——我觉得当有人把某种东西拿走时，比如我不知道，假装自己没多少钱，或者假装贫困，或者假装一直在苦苦挣扎、从来没有拥有过任何东西，然后进行角色扮演，这甚至更加冒犯。进行角色扮演。对，完全如此。百分之百。我觉得这非常重要。我一直对自己在优渥环境中长大、是一个享有特权的人、以及拥有能够资助我教育的父母这件事保持坦诚——这是一种巨大的特权。对此撒谎简直是疯了，因为大学毕业时没有背负学生贷款是一个巨大的起跑优势。在美国，这绝对是一个巨大的特权。它把你送上了一条不同的道路。它让我能够像现在这样实现经济独立。所以我觉得正如你所说，你完全是对的。有钱人，
and everyone's parents there, well, the majority of them were living in an incredibly wealthy area. And no one would really admit that like maybe they'd had a few handouts and that like maybe actually like they were doing pretty well. And there was this whole culture of like who like I think it's even more offensive when someone takes like takes the idea of like I don't know, not having much or like of poverty or like a really struggling and never having had anything and cosplay as it. And cosplay as it. Yeah, exactly. A hundred percent. I think it's so important. I've always been transparent about growing up privileged and being a privileged person and like having parents who are able to like aid me with my education. Like that is a tremendous privilege. To lie about that would be crazy because it is a massive leg up to graduate from college without student debt. Like a massive in America. Like that is a massive privilege. It sets you on a different path. It allowed me to be financially independent how I am now. So I think that to your point like you're totally right. Like people.
身处财务特权阶层的人，没有人对你感到愤怒。他们只是希望你诚实，除非你是个超级不道德的亿万富翁。对。人们只是希望你对此诚实。人们希望你对此诚实。我觉得关于强加给我的谎言，最让我沮丧的是，到目前为止，我对这一切都无比诚实。而他们却挑挑拣拣，只选择他们愿意相信的部分。
who have money and who are financially privileged, like, nobody is mad at you. They just want you to be, unless you're, you know, super unethical billionaire. Yeah. People just want you to be honest about it. People want you to be honest about it. And I think what frustrates me about lies that have been told about me is that I have been so honest about all of it so far. And they just pick and choose what to believe.
就像，我为什么现在要开始撒谎，说什么“哦，我父母给我买下了书约”之类的话？这真的很沮丧——我为什么要对此撒谎？如果真的发生过这种事，我向你保证，我会百分之百说实话的。如果我父母在为我的生活方式买单，我会对此实话实说，因为隐瞒真相会向所有人兜售一种被篡改的现实感和对可能性的错误认知——我只会像以前一样，对我在这个世界的经济地位保持诚实。而且我认为其他人也应该这样做，尤其是那些出身优渥的人——就像“哦，我父母帮我付房租”这种情况，而其他人看着你，心想你怎么能负担得起这一切，然后原因是因为他们在获得资助。我认为在20岁时非常公开地谈论这种事情真的非常重要，因为很多人都在苦苦挣扎，而且很多网红在网上发布的日常生活是人们无法理解他们怎么能负担得起的。我懂。然后我认为这会让人们在心想“这对我来说也是可能的”时走向失败，接着他们会把自己搞到破产。是的。这就像是不良引导。为了让某种形象呈现出特定外观而在互联网上隐瞒自己现实生活的真相，这是不良引导，因为人们会受到你的影响，而我试图以高度的责任感来看待这一点，并做到真正诚实。要知道，有人对我有过最大的误解，其实也非常类似。那是，是的，我记得那只是一条评论，还有一个我偶然发现的帖子——顺便说一句，千万不要在Reddit上搜索你自己。任何听众，千万别这么做。这是你一生中做过最糟糕的决定。但有人说，哦，她是个视财如命的人，因为当我签署我的播客协议时，当时我有一份全职工作，你知道的，当时大家对我要播放多少广告有很多期望，而这几乎是辞职的唯一途径。你知道，那份合同是签了很多很多年的。人们总是对播客里的广告感到沮丧。
Like, why would I start lying now about, you know, oh, like my parents bought my book deal or something like that? like that's just frustrating like why would I lie about that like if that happened I promise I would be telling the 100% truth if my parents were paying for my lifestyle I would tell the truth about that because it sells everyone a falsified sense of reality and what's possible like I'm just going to be honest about my financial place in this world as I have been and I think it's important that other people do the same other people especially who come from privilege like to the point of like oh my parents pay my rent and other people are looking at
每次有人提起这事，天哪，真的让我非常难过。我知道，我知道，这真的让我很沮丧。我怎么也想不明白——有一段时间，我的朋友们会问，为什么偏偏是这个？为什么偏偏是这件事，人们总是一说再说，而你每次都会有如此剧烈的本能反应。我想这是因为，再次说明，这其中包含了人们并不了解的全部背景，他们仅仅根据极其极其有限的一点信息就做出了假设。另外，话说回来，除了靠广告，你还能怎么付账单？
at you like how can you afford all of this and it's like because they're getting help it's it's i think really important in your 20s to be very open about that kind of stuff because a lot of people are struggling and also a lot of influencers are posting lives online that people don't understand how they could lead i know and then i think it sets people up for failure when they're like this is possible for me and then they like bankrupt themselves yes yeah it's like bad influencing it's bad influencing to omit the truth about your reality on the internet in order to make it appear a certain way because people will feel influenced by you and I try to take that with a heightened level of responsibility and like be really honest see the thing that like I like the biggest misunderstanding
他们应该为你因为能够把播客作为全职事业来运营、从而有更多时间专注于播客而感到高兴才对。而且再次证明，一个白手起家的女性在这个世界上是多么重要。我不知道为什么我们没有为更多白手起家的女性大声喝彩。相反，我们却总是不断地把她们拉下马。而且总觉得是某个男人为这一切付了钱，或者觉得她做得太多了。或者，哦，她现在变得贪财了。但一个大男人可以说“我想变有钱”，却没有人会在意。
that someone had about me was really similar and it's yeah well it was like I remember it was just one comment and one like thread that I found like just never look up yourself on Reddit by the way. Like anyone out there like just don't do it. It's the worst decision of your life. But someone was like, oh, she's money hungry because like when I signed my, you know, deal for my podcast when I had a full-time job and, you know, there were all these expectations for how many ads I would run and it was kind of the only way to be able to quit. And, you know, that contract was for, from is for, for many, many years. And people always get frustrated by ads on the podcast.
完全如此。完全如此。而且我觉得这其中，又是一次价值观的问题，你会觉得，你根本不知道我实际的生活开销远低于我的收入水平。你根本不知道我究竟赚了多少钱。也不知道我捐给家庭成员多少钱，通过慈善捐款捐了多少钱，以及我是如何帮助朋友的。我觉得这就是问题所在，你并不了解情况。我的父母总是把我抚养得——这总是回归到这个价值观——我的父母总是把我抚养得非常慷慨，总是教导我要懂得分享并回馈社会。所以当人们假设你并非如此，假设你没有被培养成那样时，对你来说，你一直被培养成一个努力工作的人，而人们却假设你不是这样的人，这简直是最深刻的创伤。
And every time someone brings it up, oh my God, it just really upsets me. And I know, I know it just, it really upsets me. And I can never figure, like, for a while, like, my friends were like, why is it this? Like, why is it this that you, people say it all the time and every time you have such a visceral reaction. And I think it's because, again, it's that there is all this context that people don't know. and they make an assumption off of a very, very limited thing. Also, it's like, how are you, how are you supposed to pay your bills, if not for ads?
而且我认为这再次归结为这样一件事：人们对事情不够诚实，并且倾向于做最坏的打算。所以你会对一个你其实一无所知的人做出最坏的假设。我并不想评判任何人。——好吧，我的确会评判那些气势汹汹冲着你来的人。但我理解他们的出发点。他们是从那些曾经撒过谎的人那里产生这种印象的。你知道我的意思吗？是的。就像，他们是从那些撒过谎的人那里得出这种看法的，因为确实有人曾这样做过。但归根结底，我认为我们需要为更多财务独立的、成功的、白手起家的女性庆祝，尤其是那些没有负面新闻、尽力做好自己并且保持诚实的女性。就像你一直以来都非常诚实一样。所以这真的太可怕了。我很遗憾。我也为你感到难过。
Like, they should be excited that you have more time to focus on the podcast because you've been able to leverage it as a full-time career. And again, a woman who is self-made is so important in this world. I don't know why we're not applauding more self-made women. And instead, we just need to tear them down constantly. And it's always like a man paid for it or she's doing too much. Or, oh, she's money hungry now. But a dude could be like, I want to be rich and nobody cares.
这，但再次说明，我喜欢我们刚才讨论的——让我们来给出一些关于如何面对被误解的建议吧。结果我们的反应是：其实我还是很生气。是的。我，是的，我觉得这很令人沮丧，对吧？但我觉得归根结底，我已经从那种情绪中解放出来了，而且既然你问到了，我才又把它提出来。然而“我父母为我的书约付了钱”、“我不资助自己的生活方式”这种想法，这些观点根深蒂固地带有性别歧视色彩，因为他们不会对我的兄弟们这么说。
Exactly. Exactly. And I think there's like, again, it's this value thing where it's like you have no idea how below my means I actually live. And like you have no idea like how much money I even make. And like the money that I give to like family members and the money that I give to like through donations and like how I help. friends like I think that's the thing where it's like you don't know and it's like my parents always
他们不会对男性这样说。而当他们把这种指责强加给那些并非出身优渥的女性时，这让我感到无比困扰。我能理解你是怎么对我和我产生这种印象的。我能看出你是怎么得出这个结论的。这说得通。但对于那些并非出身优渥的女性来说，这太具有侮辱性了。她们是彻彻底底、完全靠自己白手起家的。而这竟然就是你们要说的话？对于一个把自己带入到以前从未达到过的财务境地的人来说，说出这样的话简直是极度性别歧视，而这正是许多女性创作者和媒体领域的创业者的真实写照。
raised me to be again it always comes back to this value like my parents always raised me to be very generous and to always like take what you have and give it back and so when people assume that you're not what you've always been raised to be like for you you were always raised to be hardworking and people assume that you are not that it's like just the deepest wound that can be cut And I think it also, again, comes down to this thing of, like, people not being honest about things and thinking, so you assume the worst. Like, you assume the worst of someone that you really don't know anything about. And I don't judge anybody. Like, I do judge people for coming at you like that. But I get where they're getting it. They're getting it from people who have lied. Do you know what I
这就是重点——无论你发现自己处于什么境地，再次说明，只有你自己知道真相。但与此同时，别人也可以有他们的看法，这并不能改变你为之付出了多少努力，也无法改变幕后所有的付出。这就变成了一种心态：好吧，如果你真的相信这就是全部所需要的，那你自己去试一把啊。如果你真的相信事情就是这样的，那就试着去找另一个这样的故事，或者。对于那些显然不在我们这个圈子里的人来说，我认为这只需要保持一种坚忍的心态，心想：好吧，但这件事到底对现实情况产生了什么实际影响？
mean? Yeah. Like, they're getting it from the people who have lied because there are people who have but ultimately I just think we need to be celebrating more financially, independent, successful and self-made women, especially who are just like unproblematic and doing their best and like are honest. Like seems that you've been very honest. So that's just like so horrible. I'm sorry. I'm sorry for you as well.
这不过是些言语罢了。一个花那么多心思关注你的人，根本没有时间去思考如何提升自己、让自己变得更好。所以这就相当于，通过他们的损失换取了你的收获，对吧？就像，他们选择让你占据他们的思维空间。这其实是你的赢面。你绝对不能让这种事发生在自己身上，反过来让对方占据你的思维空间。我觉得被看见和把自己展现给公众的代价，就是遭到不喜欢。
Like it's, but again, I love how we're like, let's give, let's give advice on how to be misunderstood. And we're like, well, I'm still angry. Yeah. I, yeah, I think it's, it's frustrating, right? but like I think at the end of the day like I freed myself from that kind of stuff and you ask it about it. So I'll bring it back up. But the idea that my parents paid for my book deal, the idea that I don't fund my own lifestyle. Like those things are deeply rooted in sexism because they wouldn't
就像面对别人不喜欢你这件事，你必须要有足够的勇气去承受别人的厌恶。是的。虽然这很吓人，但却是现实。这是一大堆成功所必须付出的代价。好了。我们要进行最后一次中场休息。等我们回来，我想聊聊你的感情生活，以及一点关于你新书的事情。
say it about my brothers. They don't say it about men. And it's deeply troubling to me when they levy it at women who didn't come from privilege. Like I understand how you got there with me. Like I can see how you got there. It makes sense. women who didn't come from privilege, like, that is so insulting. Like they are completely and entirely self-made. And that's what you're going to say. Like, that is so deeply sexist to say about somebody who has put themselves in a financial situation they never would have been in before, which is true of so many female content creators
请继续收听。2%。这是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立抗压能力的秘诀。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家拨开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
and entrepreneurs in the media space. And this is the thing is like, whatever situation you find yourself in, again, you know, your truth, but also people can have those opinions and it does not change how much you have worked for this and it does not change all the effort behind the scenes. And it's this thing of like, okay, if you truly believe that this is all that it took, give it a go. Like if you truly believe that this is what happened, like try and find another story like that or like. And for people who are, you know, obviously not kind of in the space that we are in. I think it's just about having such a stoic mindset and being like, okay, but genuinely how does this impact the actual reality of
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字是T-W-P-P-Cent，在iHeart Radio上。苹果播客，或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得当年戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
the situation? It's just words. And someone who is thinking about you that much, like they don't have time to think about themselves in a way that's improving them and bettering them. So it's like you, it's your gain through their loss, right? Like, they don't have time to think about themselves in a way that's improving them and bettering them. So it's like you, it's your gain through their loss, right? Like they have chosen to like let you occupy their mind. That's a win for you. Like you just can't let that happen to you as well and let them occupy your mind. I think the cost of sort of being seen and putting yourself out there is dislike.
好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一集请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
Like the idea of people disliking you, you have to be brave enough so that people could dislike you. Yeah. Which is scary, but real. It's the cost of like a lot of success. All right. We're going to take one more break. Let me return. I want to talk about your relationship and also a little bit about your new book.
我随时都可以一整天都在聊快克，只是想让大家知道我的意思。我是说，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条内在脉络了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》（Learn the Hardway），我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却还在继续追逐。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层级。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我，吉尔·盖恩斯，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和个人。展开真实的对话，就在我的新播客《艰难成长》中。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难成长》并立即收听。2023年，前“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她谎言中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吗？
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and personal. on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要去招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要去招惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的这个新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，怎么会发生这种事？
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我一定要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。我没记错的话，你是今年还是去年订婚的？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
是的，我是去年2024年订婚的。好的，感觉怎么样？简直太神奇、太完美了。我为我们的婚礼感到无比兴奋，说实话这挺疯狂的。现在距离婚礼只有大约八个月了。感觉时间过得好快。天哪，还有八个月。筹备婚礼的时期感觉如何？
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我想你现在应该还在筹备中吧？这挺有意思的。我妈妈绝对包揽了很大一部分工作。所以这真的很有帮助。坦白说，因为要忙这整本书的情况，我其实没怎么去想婚礼的事。但我知道，一旦把出书这件事抛在脑后，而且时间更接近2026年时，差不多就会是全员出动全力以赴的状态了，所以，是的，这太疯狂了。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你办的几乎是一个小型夏日婚礼，就像初夏婚礼一样。是的。初夏婚礼，就像是夏天的序幕，我很喜欢，因为夏天是我最喜欢的季节。对。最棒了。好的，这是一个我经常被问到的问题，说到20岁，我经常听到这个问题，那就是：我怎么知道我身边的这个人是对的人？你对此有什么看法？你是怎么知道你身边的人就是对的人的？我觉得说出这句话听起来真的很烦人。我无法强调这听起来会有多烦人，但是如果你还需要问的话，那他就不是对的人。你心里自然会知道。
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Am I right in saying you got engaged this year or last year?
我向你保证，你心里会有数的。那是一种最微妙、同时也最深沉、最令人安心的感觉，就像“这就是我的真命天子，我们的未来绝无第二种可能，只有我们俩”——除了这种感觉之外我无法形容它，一切就是那么顺理成章，你自己会明白的。这并不是那种轰轰烈烈、火花四溅的感觉，而是非常微妙、非常抚慰人心的。如果你还在苦苦寻找这种感觉，说明它根本不存在。我绝对不是居高临下——我只是从未跟以前交往过的任何人，体验过现在和伴侣在一起时的那种感觉。我曾经以为其中某些人就是真命天子，但其实并不是。直到遇到了真正对的人，你才会惊呼：天哪，原来这才是那种感觉。
Yes, I got engaged last year, 2024. Okay, how was it? It was so magical and perfect. And I'm so excited for our wedding, which it's crazy. It's like eight months away now. And it feels like it happens so quickly. My gosh, eight months away. How was the wedding planning period?
是的，我去年订婚了，2024年。好的，感觉怎么样？太神奇了，太完美了。我为我们的婚礼感到超级兴奋，这太疯狂了。现在离婚礼大约还有八个月。感觉时间过得好快。天哪，还有八个月。筹备婚礼的阶段怎么样？
I guess you're still in it, right? It's interesting. My mom is definitely doing a lot of it. So that's really helpful. Frankly, with like this whole book situation, I haven't been thinking much about the wedding. But I know once the book is behind us and we kind of get closer to 2026, it's going to be sort of all hands on deck, which, yeah, it's crazy.
我想你还在筹备中吧？这很有意思。我妈妈确实帮了很多忙。所以这真的很有帮助。坦白说，由于最近这整本书的事情，我没怎么考虑婚礼的事。但我知道，一旦这本书告一段落，而且我们离2026年更近一些，就会变成全员齐心协力的时候，这确实挺疯狂的。
You're having like a little summer wedding almost, like a pre-summer wedding. Yes. Pre-summer wedding, like kick off of summer, which I love because summer is my favorite season. Yeah. the best. Okay, this is a question I get, speaking about 20s, I get all the time, which is, how do I know that I'm with the right person? What are your thoughts on that? How did you know that you were with the right person? I think it's like so annoying to say. Like I can't stress how annoying this is going to be, but like if you have to ask, it's not the right person. You will know.
你们办的几乎是一个小型夏日婚礼，就像初夏前的婚礼。是的。初夏婚礼，就像夏天的开端，我很喜欢，因为夏天是我最喜欢的季节。是的，最棒了。好的，这是一个我经常被问到的问题，说到二十多岁，我总能听到这个问题，那就是：我怎么知道我选对了人？你对此有什么看法？你是怎么知道你选对了人的？我觉得这么说真的很烦人。我简直无法强调这有多烦人，但如果你必须问这个问题，那就说明不是对的人。你会知道的。
Like I promise you, you will know. It is the most subtle and also deeply, comforting feeling of just like this is my person there's no other way this could go it's only us like i can't describe it other than that like it just makes sense and like you will know if you're it's not some big fireworks explosive feeling it's very subtle and very comforting and i think if you're searching for it it's not there and i don't mean to be condescending like at all i i just had never felt the way that i feel with my partner now with anybody else that i'd ever been with and I thought some of them were the one, but they weren't. And it took meeting the person who was to be like, damn, like, that's what it feels like
我向你保证，你会知道的。这是一种最微妙也最深沉、令人安心的感觉，就好像“这就是我的真命天子，不可能有别的结局，只有我们俩”，我无法用别的词来形容，它就是顺理成章，而且你会知道的，如果不是的话，它并不是那种轰轰烈烈、火花四溅的感觉，而是非常微妙、非常安心。我想如果你一直在寻找这种感觉，说明它并不存在。我绝不是想居高临下，绝对不是。我只是从没对以前交往过的任何人有过现在对伴侣这种感觉。我曾经以为以前有些人就是真命天子，但其实并不是。直到遇到了真正对的那个人，才感叹：天哪，原来这就是这种感觉。
to be with the right person. It's just very comfortable, very subtle, very comforting, very obvious. This is like the line that everyone always says, like, you know, you know. And I think when you, and I think again, like when you were in the situation when you're like, what do they mean by that? It's like, well, you probably haven't experienced it. You haven't felt that way. And that's okay.
和对的人在一起，就是那种非常舒服、非常微妙、非常安心、非常显而易见的感受。这就好像大家常说的那句话，懂的自然懂。我想当你处于那种情境中，心里会想，他们到底是什么意思？这就说明，你可能还没经历过，你还没那种感受，不过这没关系。
Like, it's more special if it's singular. Like it's going to come for you and who knows? Like, but why would you want to feel that a million times? Like the person that you're going to want to end up being with, like, that should be more special than the rest. So like being patient for that feeling is worth it. When do you think is the time to leave a relationship? So if you have this feeling and you're like, I'm just not sure, how much time do you think
如果它是独一无二的，就会显得格外特别。它会在未来某天降临到你身上，谁知道呢？但是，你为什么会想把这种感觉体验上百万次呢？你最后想要相伴一生的人，那份感觉应该比其余的都来得特别。所以，为那种感觉保持耐心是值得的。你觉得什么时候该结束一段感情呢？如果你有这种感觉，心里不太确定，你觉得应该给自己多少时间
you should give yourself to really maybe investigate it? If you've got like a bit of relationship anxiety or like you just found yourself being quite stressed about relationships in general. I think it depends on how long you've been in the relationship. Like if it's been like six months and you're like, I think every individual relationship is different, right? I think you just have to take the time that you need to investigate it and be real with yourself. I would talk to someone about it.
去真正审视一下这段关系？如果你有点恋爱焦虑，或者发现自己对感情问题本身感到相当压力。我觉得这取决于你谈了多久。比如如果才六个月，你会觉得每段感情都不一样，对吧？我觉得你只需要花你需要的时间去审视它，对自己诚实。我会找个人聊聊这件事。
Maybe that's a therapist, a trusted family member or friends. Sometimes like getting the feelings out into the world with someone like non-judgmental can be helpful. And then I would make your decision from there. I wouldn't linger for too long. Like I feel like the same way if you know, you know about wanting to be with someone, there isn't if you know, you know, about wanting to get out.
也许是治疗师、值得信赖的家人或朋友。有时把内心的感受向一个不会评判你的人倾诉会很有帮助。然后你就可以从那里做出决定。我不会拖太久。就像如果你知道自己想和谁在一起时那样，如果你知道自己想离开，也是一清二楚的。
And sometimes we avoid the feeling for far too long. But like the longer you avoid it, the harder it'll be. Yeah. And trust your gut. Like it's not relationship anxiety if it's been following you for months. Like if this has been like three months, six months, like there's something else going on there. There's something else going on there. And you'll feel like a huge.
有时候我们逃避这种感觉的时间太长了。但你逃避的时间越长，事情就会越难处理。是的，要相信你的直觉。如果这种感觉已经持续了好几个月，那就不是什么恋爱焦虑。如果这种情况已经持续了三到六个月，说明有别的问题正在发生。确实有别的问题在发生。而且你会感到巨大的。
sense of relief. I think like a lot of people don't want to be single and that's actually why they stay in a relationship. What's like your thoughts or advice on that predicament? I don't think like being single is inferior to being in a relationship. Like I don't see one as like a waiting room and one as a destination. I see them as like sort of equivalence or like being single can be equal to dating and can be equal to being in a relationship. You can be single and want to be in a relationship but there's like nothing wrong with being single. And I think once you realize, like, being single is not a waiting room, it gets so much better. Because like, you're like, yeah, right. Like, I was like waiting to live my life till I was in a relationship. That's sort of so sad. Like, let me just live it now.
解脱感。我觉得很多人不想单身，而这其实正是他们留在感情里的原因。你对这种困境有什么看法或建议？我不认为单身比谈恋爱低人一等。我不觉得一个就像是候车室，另一个是目的地。我觉得它们是平等的，单身可以等同于约会，也可以等同于恋爱。你可以单身并渴望恋爱，但单身并没有什么不对。而且一旦你意识到单身不是候车室，事情就会变得好很多。因为你会觉得，对啊，我以前居然在等自己谈恋爱了才开始生活，这实在太遗憾了。让我现在就开始生活吧。
I understand being scared to be single after being in a partnership for so long. But like, being scared means that you care. And I think that's a really good place to start. And not only that, like when you are scared and when you do something brave, like that's when the greatest transformations of your life happens. You have to like keep the faith that on the other side it will be good again. And I do believe that it will be. Like no one has been heartbroken for their whole entire life. It's not a thing. And even if they have, they've made amazing art from it. Like, or they have like poured that into other people. Like yeah. But even though, yeah. This is the thing like I was saying this to my friend the other day. I was like maybe that's
我理解在经历长期伴侣关系后会害怕单身。但害怕意味着你在乎，我觉得这是一个很好的起点。不仅如此，当你感到害怕却依然做出一件勇敢的事情时，你生命中最伟大的转变就会发生。你必须保持信念，相信在另一边一切都会好起来的。我相信会的。没有人会一辈子都心碎，根本没有这种事。即使他们真的心碎了，他们也会从中创作出惊人的艺术作品，或者把爱倾注到其他人身上。是的。即便如此，这就是我前几天对朋友说的话，我说也许那正是
where all the cat ladies come and there's a lot of souls that need love. And like there's always, you're always going to find love in like some form. Right. Like maybe. you maybe you will grieve this person for the rest of your life you probably most certainly won't but if you do like that means that you're going to have so so much more emotion to to put into other things as well like and that means you're going to feel very very human and also you're just like that's the worst case scenario it's obviously not going to actually occur like people people are so flexible and get over so much more and so much worse and like your heart can take so much more than than you expect um let's like turn up
所有猫咪女士的去处，那里有很多需要爱的灵魂。而且你总会在某种形式上找到爱。对吧？也许，也许你会在余生中为这个人悲伤，虽然你大概率不会，但如果你真的这样做了，那就意味着你会有更多、更多的情感可以投入到其他事情中，这也意味着你会感到非常、非常有人情味。而且你也会觉得，这已经是做最坏的打算了，它显然不会真的发生。人类适应力极强，能挺过去的事情要多得多、糟糕得多，你的心能承受的远比你想象的要多。嗯，让我们把
focus back onto your book as we wrap up. It's out now. When this episode comes out, you guys may have called on that we are recording this a little bit early, but I just had to get Eli on the show. It's out now. What is your favorite chapter or favorite takeaway from this collection of essays? I love the last chapter. Like that's probably my fave. Like if I had to choose my number one, it would be the last. I also really like the first. But my favorite thing is like getting to see what other people think of it. Like somebody's favorite chapter is not going to be one of those two that I just mentioned and I can't wait to find those little nuggets of reader feedback out once it's in the world.
焦点转回你的书上，因为我们快要结束了。这本书现在已经出版了。当这期节目播出时，大家可能会发现我们录得稍微有点早，但我必须请伊莱上节目。书已经出版了。在这本散文集中，你最喜欢哪一章或最大的收获是什么？我最喜欢最后一章，那可能最受我喜爱。如果必须选出第一名，我会选最后一章。我也很喜欢第一章。但我最喜欢的是看到其他人对它的看法。说不定别人的最爱并不是我刚才提到的那两章之一，我等不及要在书问世后去发现读者反馈的那些小亮点。
What's the last chapter on? So we all know. It is, does anyone else feel like it's okay not to know everything? The biggest fear about 20s. The fear from which all other fears stem from, I believe, the fear of like of the unheard. Yes. I can't wait to read it. We always finished with this one question, and I'm excited to hear her answer, which is,
最后一章是关于什么的？好让大家都知道。是“有没有人觉得不知道所有事情也没关系？”。这是二十岁时最大的恐惧。我相信，所有其他恐惧都源于这种恐惧，也就是对未知的恐惧。是的。我迫不及待想读它。我们的访谈总是以这一个问题结束，我也很高兴听到她的回答，那就是：
what is one thing you wish you knew sooner about your 20s or one piece of advice you would have for someone in your 20s that has nothing to do with what we discussed today? I would say, like, don't try to waste it away. Don't try to be like onto the next all the time. I think there was a large chunk of my 20s that I like was just so wanting to like be out of that phase out of my skin into a different phase into a different moment and I just like really regret not living in the present more. So I would say just like lean into the moment even if it's uncomfortable, sticky, shitty, awful, you hate it. You're never going to get the time back. And who knows what
有什么事是你希望自己早点知道的关于二十岁的道理，或者对二十岁的人有什么建议，是和我们今天讨论的内容完全无关的？我想说的是，不要把时间虚度了。不要总是想着赶快进入下一个阶段。我觉得在我二十岁时很大的一段时间里，我都迫切地想要摆脱那个阶段，摆脱当前的自己，进入一个不同的阶段、不同的时刻，我真的很后悔没有更多地活在当下。所以我想说的是，勇敢去享受当下，即使它很不舒服、很棘手、很糟糕、很可怕、你讨厌它。你再也无法找回这段时间了。谁知道
the future holds. Yeah. Respect all seasons. They're there for a reason. Even I love that. Even the terrible ones. Yeah. Well, I want to thank you again for coming on the podcast. Where can everybody find you? You can find me on Instagram, Eli at Eli.ralo and TikTok at Eli Rallo. And you can get the book wherever you buy books. Yeah, you can get both books. I will leave them in the description below. They have really cool covers as well. Oh my gosh.
未来会怎样。是的。尊重每一个季节，它们存在自有其道理。甚至我也喜欢这样。甚至是那些糟糕的季节。是的。嗯，我想再次感谢你来到播客。大家在哪里可以找到你？你可以在Instagram上找到我，账号是Eli at Eli.ralo，在TikTok上是Eli Rallo。你可以在任何买书的地方买到这本书。对，两本书都可以买到。我会把链接留在下方的描述栏里。它们的封面也真的很酷。天哪。
Thank you. I appreciate that. The cover, like I remember when you announced like your second book, I was like, that's a really sexy cover. Thank you. Thank you. People are going to love it. Thank you again for joining us.
谢谢。我很感激。封面，我记得当你宣布第二本书的时候，我还想过，这真的是一个非常性感的封面。谢谢，谢谢。大家会喜欢的。再次感谢你加入我们。
As always, if you enjoyed the episode, please leave a five-star review. you wherever you are listening. Make sure you're following along and follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast to see the other guests we have coming on this December as well as just keep up behind the scenes. Stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请在你收听的地方留下五星好评。确保关注我们，并在Instagram上关注我们@that psychology podcast，看看我们今年12月会邀请哪些其他嘉宾，并了解幕后花絮。注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《百分之二》。就在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对对我来说是一个巨大的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生的事情，并尝试与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜爱的作家一起，理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。在那之前，那是一个狂野的年份。那是一个狂野的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men. experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不太安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何处理这些问题的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。奥恩斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the EyeHour
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的推进，劳拉·奥恩斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客
Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
心电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the iHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在iHeart radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。